well hello everyone and welcome to
today's google cloud next session
during cloud ai week my name is addison
and i'm joined by my colleague
phil we're both members of the capitol
competitions team
and we're excited to speak with you
today specifically about tpus
and tensorflow on kaggle
but first what's cac historically kaggle
has become synonymous with
machine learning competitions but it's
really much much more than that
calgary data science platform over 5
million data scientists from all over
the world come to kaggle to not only
not only participate in machine learning
competitions but
to learn data science build their skills
polish their portfolios and share data
sets and code
it's truly an incredibly exciting
community
now my job at kaggle is to run machine
learning competitions
and they run the gamut right now we have
17 competitions running
ranging from understanding bird sounds
predicting
lung function decline classifying
melanoma
nlp challenges and even a bot building
simulation competition
among many others we recently wrapped up
a competition with a one million dollar
prize and detected deep fakes and videos
we had competitions recently with both
the ncaa and the nfl
and even abstract reasoning challenge
with francois chalet
by the way if you haven't seen his
recent paper titled
on the measure of intelligence i mean
it's pretty amazing
i really should encourage you to check
that out after this after this session
but basically if you're interested in
data or machine learning in any form or
fashion
we've likely got a competition that will
excite you
and really one of the most exciting
elements of kaggle is that as the home
of data science
professionals hobbyists thought leaders
and academics
will come to kaggle to test new theories
technologies
and potential advancements in the
state-of-the-art
machine learning now we've been very
fortunate to witness
the birth or the spread and
dissemination of many of the leading
data science techniques
from back when random force decision
trees kind of took over
to light gbms xg boost
in the introduction of libraries like
paris
so what better community to introduce
great technologies like tensorflow and
tpus
than through capital competitions the
community is filled with data scientists
who are
eager to experiment and quickly uncover
the benefits
and shortcomings of newly introduced
products
and methodologies and the kaggle
competition can provide a structured and
engaging format
to test them out and specifically for
tpus and tensorflow
our competition platform allows us to
host really large data sets
and offer both time and resource
constrained formats
that can help truly capture the power
and understand the benefits
of these particular tools it's about to
check out the latest tensorflow edition
calling it 2.x as they continue to be
updated on the
platform especially with gpu or tpu
kaggle makes it easy
you can see from the list on this slide
that we've eliminated a lot of the
obstacles to making tensorflow 2.x
build your models fast and with with
next to no specialized code
no provisioning of the right kind of vm
no setup
we already have data sets that are ready
to go our cloud notebook platform
removes the burden of needing to
reconcile versions or libraries or
packages
across collaborators so sharing and
iterating the is a breeze
and finally we even provide a weekly
allotment to tpu and gpu time
at no cost to our users all over the
world
the integration benefits afforded to
tensorflow also apply to tpus
they're directly accessible from our
kaggle notebooks without any additional
setup
we have generous data sets that are
accessible via google cloud storage that
allow for efficient data access
30 hours of tpu use per week are granted
to each user
we've even hosted five competitions just
in the last six months
aimed at these particular tools most
recently we hosted a competition
that was tpu-centric with the google
team jigsaw
that was seeking to evaluate and
classify toxic comments on wikipedia
we also just launched a competition
called contradictory my dear watson
which seeks to use tpus and natural
language processing to evaluate grammar
but today we want to look specifically
at our first two competitions
introduced cpus to over 5 million data
scientists
first being tensorflow 2.0 question
answering and the second being one on
flower classification
now tensorflow is already very heavily
used in our competitions
it's currently being used in all of our
running competitions but
in the past few months we've run two
tensorflow competitions that i mentioned
this one on top being a question
answering nlp
competition built around the launch of
tensorflow 2.0
and a new competition for image
classification that introduced
tpus for the first time to our platform
we already have tens of thousands of
people using tensorflow 2.x
right now to solve problems and three of
the top
solutions in the question answering
competition ended up using tensorflow
and tpus and so next we want to do is
let's dive into some of the code
let's look at some of the code right now
that will build a model on kaggle
for our competition to classify flowers
on cpu
gpu and tpu with no changes so phil
i'm going to hand it over to you to walk
through some of the cochlear use
competitions
thanks addison we start off simple by
importing tensorflow 2
and the kaggle datasets library the rest
of the code here does a bit of magic
it figures out what kind of accelerator
is attached to your vm and allows us to
automatically parallelize your model
building
this will return an appropriate strategy
whether using a v3 tpu
or a simple cpu vm basically this code
asks for a tpu and if it gets one it
connects to it and sets it up
if it can't get a tpu it sets that up as
well the rest of the code in these
slides is entirely accelerator agnostic
normally outside of kaggle and colab
you'd need to provision this tpu for
usage and do some other setup
but on our platform that's not necessary
just select the tpu from the drop-down
and go
now we load up our competition data set
it's provided in charted tf record
format for fast loading
we use multiple files to provide enough
data streams to maximize the tpu's
throughput
first we get the path to those tf record
files and pass it to tensorflow
then set some parameters for our
training and validation sets
shuffling our training set batching both
sets for optimal performance
setting our training set to repeat so
it'll loop back around with the g-puck
we'll pass these into our model and
tensorflow will access these tf record
files while the model is building
the end result of this process is that
we have datasets ready to run in our
accelerator of choice
this code does some heavy lifting here
we load up vgg16 for some transfer
learning
and then define our model by adding a
global average pooling and output layer
on top of that
note the width strategy.scope block
that's basically saying hey
whichever type of acceleration strategy
you're using here this is the process to
parallelize
now our model will be compiled and
trained on the accelerator we've chosen
note again that this same code will run
on cpu gpu or tpu
as long as we identify our distribution
strategy tensorflow 2 automatically
handles putting this model in the right
place and building it
after this we compile our model with our
choice of optimizer and loss
pass the training and validation sets
from the previous slide into it
and start the model fitting process
making some flower predictions is easy
after this we load up our test data set
using the same type of code that we use
to load the training and validation sets
once again this results in data that
makes the best use of our tpu
then we run model.predict transform our
predictions into the right form
and write our predictions out in the
format that kaggle can read with a few
tweaks
and a few more epochs this model can
actually score pretty well
i'll finish the code section with some
of the fun flowers that our model has
made predictions on
you can see that some are right they've
got a little okay above them and some
are wrong if you're interested you're
more than welcome to drop by the pedals
to the metal competition
and beat these results that won't be
hard but it will probably be fun
and now addison back to you
thanks phil uh i still demonstrated in
his code review using tpus on kaggle
it's a super easy way
um to get used to tpus in the flower
competition assume the flower
classification competition
that phil highlighted we had over 24 000
tpu using sessions by kaggle users and a
very small amount needed
any amount of help to get started thanks
to some getting started work
done by some members of the team over 80
percent of users needed no help to begin
using tpus
as you can see in this screenshot of top
kaggle notebooks in the flower
classification competition
users quickly created and shared their
own tpu based notebooks
and began to train each other with
discussion topics and highly uploaded
notebooks
many of these top notebooks came from
kaggle's highest ranked
grand master users it's really exciting
to see data science community very
quickly learning
themselves so they can then quickly
teach others
so let's highlight some very specific
outcomes this competition in a kaggle
notebook
users can elect to use a cpu gpu or tpu
like phil mentioned
so we pick two of the top performing
models using each tpus
and gpus they each use effectively the
same code
the tpu model trained on 25 000 images
in an hour and 15 minutes and that same
model would run out of memory
when they try to flip it over gpus the
comparative gpu model
took five hours to train those same 25
000 images
but they had to be able to reduce size
in the end the accuracy still didn't
prove competitive with the tpu model
now prior to this competition there have
been some slight murmurings of tv use
but once the first competition was
launched in february of this year you
can see the large
jump in discussion four mentions per
month about tpus
and it continued to rise now as we
introduce more competitions
including a competition designed to help
introduce tpus to the uninitiated
we're looking forward to seeing how not
just discussion of tpus and tensorflow
continuity increase
but how the data science community
continues to find great insights
in their spread so if you're interested
in seeing tensorflow 2 at work on kaggle
come check it out try out the code that
phil just showed you
compete in the flower competition or try
it out with a data set of your choice
we're traveling with our past
competitions or on our hosted notebook
platform where we give you
some tpu hours to play with in the
coming months we'll be launching
even more competitions so you can
leverage the power of tensorflow
and tpus on capital now it's been a big
group
effort i want to give a special thanks
to martin garner who is the devrel
program manager project manager who led
the effort to integrate tpus
so thanks so much to him for his hard
work it's pretty awesome to see how easy
it is to use tips for flow and kaggle
right now and so finally thanks to you
for joining us with our session today
thank you for your time
please come visit us over at the dory
we'll be hanging out all week
answering any questions you may have
about tpus and tensorflow on cattle
and again thanks so much have a great
day